the country seeing a spike in the
coronavirus cases and hospitalizations
new york governor andrew cuomo
responding by bringing back strict
measures um no
finally bars and restaurants and gyms in
the state are now being forced to close
at 10 o'clock in indoor gatherings of
private residents
will be limited to 10 people all get a
turnstile and then turn in the final
count
we did get some good news on a potential
covet 19 vaccine this week but some
americans may have to wait until the
rest of the world gets it first
that is if a biden advisor called zeke
emanuel gets his way
he urged officials to follow the fair
priority model
which calls to distribute a vaccine
globally before it's available to all
americans katie is that okay with you
let's make sure the russians have all
they need before we head
out to montana and new mexico well the
russians apparently have their own
vaccines all right
well vladimir putin won't take it yeah
they can have their own um
no i don't think that's okay i think the
united states needs to get back on its
feet are a u.s company has developed the
vaccine
the president has put in place a plan
for distribution through the pentagon
and the military and they're going to
get it to the most vulnerable
populations first so the rest of the
economy
can get on track and the idea that we
would be obligated to somehow share it
with the rest of the world and does this
include china
i don't know but i want to talk about
the restrictions as well the new
restrictions the threats of another
lockdown
you know if you remember back in in may
and june when
they started you know their questions
about how long the lockdown was going to
go
15 days to 30 days people were willing
to do it for a little while
lockdowns didn't necessarily stop
because politicians thought that it was
fine to do it they stopped because
people started
fighting back you had that woman in
texas who opened her salon went to jail
over it you have a number of people
saying i can't feed my family
if you continue these lockdown measures
and also if it's based on science we saw
and i said this yesterday
governor cuomo admitted that 63 of new
cases in new york
earlier this year came from people who
were locked down
and so you know you have to balance out
the consequences of another lockdown
with
with the consequence you've seen of
people not being able to provide for
their families i mean it's just
there are real serious consequences to
people who can't make a living lightning
round uh jesse lockdowns don't work
and if he's going to go back to what he
did he steamrolled the entire city
and says he won the whole city went to
its knees
it's going to take decades to recover he
wants more of that formula or he wants
to just put this in his paperback
yeah he wrote a book about all this the
last couple months and now cases are
rising what kind of an
idiot does something like that and
everybody here i see is wearing a mask
in new york city so why are cases rising
i don't understand it i do know this
joe biden wants to give the vaccine to
the chinese before to the united states
that is insane that is literally insane
here's some more insanity
the biden kovid advisor says this
u.s lockdowns of four to six weeks could
control the pandemic and revive the
economy
they want more lockdowns month long
lockdowns and they say don't worry we'll
just
send everybody checks so they can get by
dana lockdowns don't work but we're
going back to it sweden didn't lock down
they have the same situation as germany
who did
europe is supposed to doing it the right
way and they're flat on their back well
the other thing is i don't understand so
restaurants have to close at 10 p.m but
does that mean that the coronavirus
doesn't spread at night everybody knows
that everybody knows that at 11 o'clock
the virus goes into that
got it got it i also think that you know
american taxpayers are on the hook
for a lot of the funding of not only the
production of this vaccine but the
distribution of it
i do think that after that we should
help others when we can but we should
make sure that people in this country
get it first
want do you think a lockdown for the
next two or three months
is the way merkel says lock down for
thanksgiving
and you'll have a christmas is that the
formula for success wait do they have
thanksgiving
about our thanksgiving i don't translate
i only took three years of germany
go ahead you know you're snorkeling
compared to my deep dive friend look
i just want to say i think you've
mis-framed this whole segment i got to
tell you something
to me pfizer an american company is
already working with a german company
so it's already an international effort
and you as long as you have airplanes
flying around
the virus is an international global
concern
and what you heard from zika manual is
not saying americans don't get the
vaccine
in sufficient doses to take care of our
problem he's saying
once we get the vaccine in sufficient
numbers to lower our infection
rate below one percent then we should
make an effort to go look for other
people
that's a whole different it's not it's
not like saying oh they're ignoring
us good americans they're ignoring
people in montana that's just not fair
america first one
i'm fine i'm fine everybody okay but i
mean that's
to say oh that's what he's saying that's
not what z commander was saying
he named it he said priority model he
said once you get a hurt immunity
then we're going to give it to the point
and then the second point the second
point to katie's argument is this
to really get the economy back in shape
we need to take steps the economy can't
recover if we still have fights you
don't
shut the economy down so the economy
recovers
politicians should actually take their
own advice first instead of running
around in crowds when it's convenient
for them while they keep other people
locked down you're making a political
argument but i'm saying health-wise the
scientists are saying here's the
prescription
we locked down it didn't work so stop
that that's not why we're wearing
we can't lock down again uh the american
people are going to revolt